[Music]
players get to choose their own walk-up
music this is how the game has evolved
you can now choose the music that plays
when you're walking up to the plate
alright to take your swings and a lot of
players go with heavy metal you have
made some different choices this year
care to talk about that well yeah I know
what you're hinting at and I've been
kind of people got confused they got
really confused because normally you
know I've always been like especially
earlier in my career I was heavy metals
like Slipknot Korn like I'm gonna be
angry at the baseball and there was one
year where me and Geoff Blum one of my
teammates I was on the Astros we decided
it would be really funny to come out to
the cheesiest song we could possibly
come out to yeah you know no one else
got it but we loved it and yeah I chose
you know Katy Perry California Girls so
hot will not be possible wait what's the
line that would be huge literally it
would come out and it would be like you
know California girls are undeniable so
hot will melt your popsicle
[Laughter]
[Applause]
love love that I'd say honestly like I
was so funny that he couldn't take it
serious so I would be like so relaxed I
hit really well yeah so did you get a
lot of give other teammates that other
players give you a hard time was it I
mean there was a ton of confusion like
like fans would come up to me and be
like what do you what are you walking up
to why are you doing that like you
didn't get it but then once they caught
on that it was a joke they loved it like
kids were like you know my little niece
she's like you know waving her hands I'd
have come out to It's Raining Men I've
always I would come out to that Hank
Williams jr. are you ready for some
football no we're not you know maybe we
need some more suggestions of like
random stuff that you don't really just
sound effects yeah Frasier Frasier this
year in Cincinnati was coming out to
like I love you from Frank Sinatra like
that was like Frank Sinatra's always I
mean it's cool but I know it's well well
at will case you mentioned Katy Perry
and you did it first as a joke since
then you've been listening to more Katy
Perry music do you got did you get
hooked I love Katy Perry absolutely but
the kind of the joke is we're on that
we're on the flight to st. Louis and you
know we're flipping through the movies
and you know on the airplane I'm seeing
some of the movies and there's a movie
that's like you know Katy Perry part of
me I'm like ooh that looks kind of
interesting but I would never watch this
on like the plane fight I'm Way too
tough for that so yeah the other players
were very macho environment yeah macho
environment can't be watching like Katy
Perry and you know so I get on the bus
and Vogelsong sits next to me bogus song
you know Philadelphia Vogel strong super
tough heals you know we're talking on
the bus everyone's talking he's like you
know I watched that Katy Perry part of
main movie
and maybe it was really awesome and we
all start having this huge discussion
like and I'm like man he had the courage
to watch that and tell us so I was like
totally shocked so the next in the next
flight you know we're flying to Detroit
and it's the World Series and I'm like
okay I'm doing it you know I'm gonna
toughen up
I'm gonna watch Katy Perry I'm gonna do
Vance you make it sound like this is
like the toughest thing you ever did and
not only did I do it I tweeted about it
I let the people know that Katy Perry
part of me was a wonderful movie I
highly recommend it
[Applause]